[Music]
[Applause]
is I'm not exactly
[Music]
oh my god it has to be my dad had an
Apple computer and it was a big deal
because it was it was the 90s like early
90s and nobody had it yet um I feel like
I didn't understand what the internet
was I normally played a bunch of like
disney games that were like disney a jew
tainment games that were like oh how
many like apples did Aladdin steal
before Jasmine I played a lot of like
dis games like that and if you like to
me I thought that was the Internet
um I didn't realize that that was like
the computer but like this game was the
Internet but then I just think I played
like this flash game online and I think
it was called munchies which sounds real
crazy but uh it was like the first like
flash game so I played around with the
internet with um like aim and that type
of thing like chatting but it was a lot
more for school there was a lot of like
having to use and carta and stuff like
that so caught up yeah like um where
it's like an online encyclopedia oh you
learned to reference things when you
write book reports and stuff and for me
the internet wasn't like fun it was
definitely made for like school and
library related things so the first time
I felt like oh my god like this is the
internet like it connected me to the
world was when I played this bizarre
flash game like I said munchies where
you're basically like eating it's
basically fishy like you just get bigger
and bigger as you keep these things on
the screen and I realized it was the
internet because whatever my dial-up
would fail it would fail and that's when
I realized like oh like I get it now
like the game connection and all those
things need to have to kind of be in the
same like ecosystem and that was a big
deal for me because I feel like I
understood for the first time almost
like the meta that it was the Internet
and I was kind of young for so I was
just like oh okay this is where like the
gateway is to the world Oh kind of
bizarre like I said a lot of it had to
do with education so it wasn't it like
instantly like oh I'm having like so
much fun with the Internet so yeah
content creating is in a very weird
universe right now I'd say um definitely
it sucks because you have to treat it
like a business right like it you want
it to be an art and you want to simply
be a creator but at the end of the day
you have to have an audience and you do
have to sell it in one way shape or form
to people so I feel like as much as the
motivation and ambition comes from
wanting to create whatever your own
personal form of entertainment or artist
you have to brand yourself and you have
to make it easy for people to recognize
you and find you and understand what it
is that you do just by quickly looking
at you so I would say that like brand
awareness and savviness although that
sounds so business it's it's so
important like um I feel like a lot of
my success is in part due to the fact
that it's very easy to understand what I
do just by looking at me um I have like
blonde hair and I'm Japanese and I
translate anime so it's all kind of in
the same like world and it's not
difficult to like look at maybe like oh
that's the one that does the anime stuff
and that's all you really need to at
least have that connection and I feel
like when you create content you have to
decide whether you are gonna be the
subject or if something else is gonna be
the subject and I think that is what you
have to just kind of clean we decide
early on which is so hard like how can
you know yourself it's like asking a
high school student what you want to do
for like the rest of your career so it's
tough but yeah that's my number one
suggestion like really like look at what
you are as a whole and what you want to
put out there and see if it kind of
works together in like a clean sentence
basically if you can explain what you do
in like two sentences you're good to go
she's good you got that bright you're
great yeah you got the brand the
business side of it you've really love
very much like good for you like it is
it's a huge like there's nothing more
that you can be doing like that's really
what you need to be doing that nobody's
at the content you create but the way
that you connect to your audience as
well and the way that you present
yourself and present your brand and
especially with like the nerd culture
there's so much ability now to kind of
like have these like subcultures and
these like many diverse things that you
could be doing and there's definitely an
audience for it's just kind of a matter
tapping into it so it's kind of cool if
you're into what you're making you'll
know most about it and you'll know where
the audience is so it kind of helps but
yeah it's tough
okay cosplay is weird um I feel like it
has expanded so much in the past five
years even since I have kind of stopped
doing it so much um I started really
young it was really just for fun I
really love Pokemon and I really love
like video games so I wanted to just be
those characters especially because in
anime and video games like they're so
artistically and stylistically specific
that you're not gonna look like them
with the big eyes and all those things
but it's really fun to kind of like get
their outfit right and my mom is a
pretty big artist like she is like
traditional like fine classical artist
so I had a lot of wanting to do crafts
with my hands because of her however I
will say it's taken a different and
interesting route I love that it is so
in-your-face and everybody's doing it
and open but when I was into it it was
definitely more embarrassing and it was
more like you have to make your own
thing because no one's gonna make it for
you and you can't let other people know
what your interview cuz that's like a
little bit too weird it's like I
remember being like crazy into
Cardcaptor Sakura but a little bit like
I was a little bit too old for it and
I'm like I don't want to tell people I'm
watching these like two middle schoolers
fall in love and catch cards at night
like it's hard to explain so I was like
yeah I just you know it's a Halloween
costume you'd blame it on with you there
there are quite a lot of highlights um
nostalgia highlights I would have to say
I'm realizing now as I grew up a little
bit in the industry more um that source
that really was a big deal and I maybe
took it for granted a little bit during
the time because now I look back on the
videos and especially like BTS videos
it's so functional and we all kind of
have the same agenda and that's
extremely rare so seeing that definitely
is a highlight because I'm like oh this
is where I learned everything and I
can't believe this was like that big and
it touched that many parts and it like
was shown on so many screens across
everybody's homes so that like reality
is a big deal kind of coming to terms
with that um but for me personally I'd
say because anime is a big big part of
my life I got to voice in the original
Japanese production of an anime in
Japanese so that was definitely one of
the biggest deals um
Japan is very bizarre the way they
handle business especially entertainment
and IP is very very muddled over in
Japan which is why licensing is always
kind of problematic and a big deal which
is also why ready player one was an
issue because Ultraman is a problem in
Japan will not release Ultraman oh yeah
it's actually Japan's fault installed
Godzilla and ultraviolet kick in the
movie under different contexts with
other people because of their licenses
and they have a legacy license from the
70s oh yeah back to brain uh but yes so
being in like that anime industry from
the US side and then kind of like almost
infiltrating and being able to be a part
of the Japanese production was a very
big deal for me and it was very
nerve-racking and scary but yeah
definitely one of the biggest things to
ever happen in my career because at the
end where the end credits go all there
are all these Japanese names and then
there's Rita Scully and English which I
asked on purpose for so yeah that was a
big deal
quite different it's seeming to be
getting a little bit closer to what it
is more in the West but it's definitely
still more nerdy Japan's really
interesting because there are two sides
to it where anime manga those things
although they're cartoons Japan doesn't
really consider them cartoons or its own
different medium it's just a different
type of entertainment so adults read
manga on the train like these
businessmen are like watching berserk
and anime and everything and it's really
really quite normal over there but
gaming I would say is done often like
obviously in handhelds and at home but
it's not as nearly openly competitive
the way eSports is here I mean I'm sure
there it is and it exists of course
because it's Asian but it's not as like
celebrated the way Sports is over there
I feel like gaming is still a little bit
more inside and with the help of other
nerd cultures like anime there's a lot
of like making fun of it and
introspecting in a really fun way so
everyone gets to kind of be in on the
inside joke of like oh I'm gonna Taku at
home and I play games for myself but
because there are so many tropes about
it that ended up being very funny and
they're utilizing it really well in
anime I feel like it is kind of bleeding
into normal culture the way the Western
society is it's just a little bit slower
Japan's really archaic much like the way
I explained how they do business there's
a lot of don't ask and therefore don't
tell kind of things going on in there oh
it sounds like I would love to find yeah
interesting cuz like Japan seems so in
your face with their bizarre unas and
their like variety shows and their games
and stuff but the reality is like when
you go there it's actually like it not
hidden but it's under like one layer of
something else and there's kind of like
a politeness layer that covers it and
you don't really get to feel it entirely
but um but then if you go to like
Akihabara which is like electric town
literally the mecca of video game and
anime it's very different it's very
front-facing so yeah
I'm a big slice of life comedy fan I'm
I'm into action and drama and like
fantasies but I kind of have to like
recalibrate my brain for those things
but um slice of life really gets me I
would say this current season
ah so Vyasa fussing is very fun CHEO
school road is incredible and I believe
things like nichijou and daily lives of
high-school boys just got added into
crunching wheels q so I'm watching that
right now and otherwise obviously attack
on Titan and mhm and like you have to
your name has a lot to do with Japanese
culture and it's actually very subtle
and it's really laced in there and it
has a lot to do with how a city kid
grows up versus like a country bumpkin
and a country country bumpkin yeah
that's uh that's what Anaka people are
called it's with people that are just
like bored off - like out of the cities
and normally in like a farming village
or town and usually those yanaka
families have a little bit more of a
stronger tie to Shinto Buddhism and
Japan isn't really tremendously
religious necessarily there it's just
more about tradition and it very subtly
goes into it and explains how it's
really alive in everyday culture but
nobody's like necessarily sitting down
and praying or going to church like the
bar of entry for that religion isn't
that high so I feel like it really shows
you how they live their daily lives
while having this kind of really
powerful tradition behind them and
culture that really cultivated this
whole country and it's very interesting
and very important I think to watch it
in Japanese
infinity war was amazing I'm actually
not the biggest superhero fan um I love
anime obviously and that superhero
almost trope is very different in anime
it's actually like an overpowered
concept so I never liked it it's always
it always seemed kind of too easy of a
scapegoat like oh I'm I just have
superpowers obviously that's not the
case there's obviously a huge history
behind it but for how I saw it it was
very like just in your face like that
but um the Avengers is really different
um the way they have paced obviously the
whole story is kind of crazy and now
like we're kind of growing up with it so
really like it's very mesmerizing
but infinity war I was able to follow
each of the micro stories which is gonna
rare for me I'm always like what's the
overall that's happening what are the
space politics right now um but with
this one it was easy to follow the
action was incredible the introduction
and like lacing in like the whole
Wakanda like that Black Panther concept
was done so well and I think a mark of a
good movie is being like you cannot wait
for the next one what's gonna happen to
Cherie my favorite character my favorite
car I'm just not an Avenger I don't care
so my favorite character